or le pass annie terre s'il apparaît
comme un outil nécessaire aux
déconfinement et à la reprise du
tourisme peut-il être aussi une
véritable arme géopolitique c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en parler nous sommes avec joëlle
mélin députée européenne pour le
rassemblement national à bonsoir madame
merci des marchés cno en direct sur rt
france vous êtes un contre justement se
passa ni terre vous allez nous dire
pourquoi dans quelques instants à vos
côtés face à vous bruno m'égare ban chef
du service réanimation de l'hôpital
lariboisière et vous êtes pour se passer
ni terre vous allez vous aussi nous
expliquer vos raisons merci à tous les
deux d'être là alors pour commencer à
une réaction aux propos de clément bonin
le vaccin spoutnik v qui ne sera pas
reconnu par le passé ni terre européen
ça pose plein de questions on va aller
développer évidemment même chose pour le
vaccin chinois médicalement déjà bruno
megaman ça vous paraît justifiée
l'écouté le vaccin spoutnik 1 publié ses
résultats dans la revue lancet tu pour
la phase iii
donc ces résultats avait l'air tout à
fait correcte avec une expérimentation
bien mené néanmoins il faut savoir que
dans les semaines qui ont suivi la
publication de cet article
certains scientifiques européens ont
contesté un certain nombre de ces
données notamment l'accès aux données a
été refusé par les auteurs ils ont
relevé un certain nombre de résultats
incohérents un changement au sein même
de l'étude avec une modification du
critère de jugement
quelques confusions concernant les
patients sélectionnés inclut les auteurs
d'ailleurs 2
russes ont répondu en disant qu
effectivement peut-être il y avait
certaines erreurs typographiques dans
l'article néanmoins le vaccin spoutnik
donné de résultats favorables dans les
pays où il a été utilisé notamment en
argentine
donc on voit bien que je pense que le
vaccin est très probable en de qualité
malgré tout il ya encore quelques
incohérences lié peut-être à des
difficultés d'accès aux données par les
scientifiques
en tout cas le dossier scientifique est
actuellement en cours d'étude par l'
agence européenne du médicament en vue
d'obtenir une à mêmes éventuelles alors
il paraîtrait que il faut au moins
encore quelques semaines de plus et donc
là la réponse finale serait pour le mois
de juillet ce qui fait en fait que à ce
moment là effectivement l'europe aurait
suffisamment de doses d autres vaccins
actuellement à gré pour ne pas avoir à
recourir aux vaccins spoutnik
ce d'autant plus que les capacités de
production de ce vaccin sont limitées
donc on voit bien qu effectivement il y
a à la fois un problème administratif
un problème peut-être scientifique ou
certaines zones d'ombré persistent et
peut-être même on peut pas l'écarter un
problème de géopolitique effectivement
j'aurais le mais là c'est étonnant parce
qu'on rappelle quand même que plus de 57
pays utilisent le vaccin rue sans
compter les nombreux qui utilisent le
vaccin chinoise que clairement on est en
train de faire de de la politique et
même de la géopolitique dans cette
affaire on en avait beaucoup parlé déjà
à l'époque où thierry breton avait fait
sa sortie prévenant il y a déjà
plusieurs semaines qu'on en aurait pas
besoin de ce vaccin russe
en europe oui mais à écouter mon
confrère à qui est encore plus qualifiés
que moi pour avoir accès aux toutes les
études en cours vous a parfaitement
démontré qu'il s'agit d'un problème
purement politique
les mains a été saisie je crois fin
février ou début mars de la demande de
spoutnik propos du spoutnik il fait ses
preuves ailleurs avec comme tous les
autres d'ailleurs une réelle incertitude
quant à l'efficacité on a manifestement
des résultats encourageants on ne peut
pas aller contre tout cela mais il ya
quand même une part d'incertitude et
l'attitude européenne qui consiste à
retarder précisément au moment même où
les chaînes de production qui ont été
aidés par les préachats européen et
toutes les subventions européennes de
l'an dernier tous ses chaînes de
production vont être à plat vont faire
en sorte que nous n'aurons pas forcément
besoin du street nique
il s'agit là d'une utilisation de la
santé à des fins politiques qui à titre
personnel me choque profondément
je crois que si on enlevait pu vacciner
plus de français mais même dans tout le
monde beaucoup plus de personnes avec
les autres vaccins que ce soit le
spoutnik que ce soit le sinopharm ou
même d'autres possibilités qu'ils ont et
de fait leurs preuves
toujours pareil avec la marge d'erreur
dans d'autres pays on aurait dû pouvoir
le faire c'est tout à fait inadmissible
et là je trouve que roux part sur une
instrumentalisation de la santé mais
nous en parlons peut-être tout à l'heure
elle est aussi totalement
instrumentalisée honneur au niveau
européen avec tous les nouveaux textes
que nous sommes en train de travailler
et bien évidemment avec la résultante
quand cet épisode là sera passée une
énorme bourde de donner une banque de
données du vivant de tout ce qu'il ya de
plus intime de la personne à propos de
la santé et là on part dans des domaines
où l'europe a prouvé qu'elle ne pouvait
pas chez n'ont pas sécurisé ces données
bruno mega man c'est vrai que ce que
souligne joëlle mélin on rappelle quand
même que c'est vexant russe
on savait susciter pas mal de moqueries
à l'époque mais enfin il est disponible
quand même depuis août dernier depuis
l'été ça veut dire concrètement en quoi
sans vous faire dire ce que ce que vous
ne pouvez pas dire parce qu'on n'a pas
de preuves bien évidemment
enfin on aurait peut-être pu sauver des
vies et on se rend compte aujourd'hui
vous c'est pas compliqué 1,2 de voir un
petit peu la main d'oeuvre qui consiste
à dire là bas bien trop tard maintenant
que vous avez l'autorisation n'a plus
besoin de vous alors je dirais bon à mon
niveau je ne peux pas donner
d'informations concernant évidemment les
raisons de d'achat ou de ne pas de ne
pas avoir acheté ce soit simplement n'ai
pas de raison de penser que ce vaccin ne
soit pas efficace pour prévenir les
formes graves de lakovic 19 et ne soit
pas suffisamment efficace pour réduire
la circulation du virus alors il est
vrai que l'europe au départ avaient misé
sur d'autres vaccins il est vrai aussi
que les capacités de production du
vaccin spoutnik par la russie sont assez
limités et donc finalement obtenir les
vaccins venant des des fournisseurs
agréés pour le moment par l'agencé
européenne du médicament est peut-être
plus simple que de faire appel à la
russie maintenant moi je suis confiant
je crois que si l'europe n'utilise pas
les vaccins russe il ya suffisamment
d'individus sur la planète qui ont
besoin de vaccination est bien qu'on
utilise ce vaccin très probablement
efficace pour vacciner protéger tous ces
humains car évidemment comme tout le
monde le sait nous ne pouvons nous
débarrasser de la pandémie quand
vaccinant la totalité de l'humanité
alors il ya aussi les questions
économiques là je m'adresse à la députée
européenne que vous n'êtes quand on sait
ce que représente les touristes chinois
l'été pour le tourisme en france qui a
bien besoin qu'on lui redonne un petit
coup voilà deux fois est-ce que c'est
judicieux cette sortie du secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes parce
qu'il n'ya pas que le vaccin russe on le
rappelle est aussi les vaccins chinois
ça fait beaucoup de monde
écoutez le souci qu'on a avec les
politiques neuf actuelles
qui sont dans un dogmatisme totalement
réducteur
j'entends bien que tout le monde a envie
de pouvoir aller et venir surtout à la
veille de l'été donc on puisse se
trouver avec un passeport tel qu'il est
appelé mais tout simplement un signe que
l'on n'ait pas contaminants de part et
d'autre de frontières puisque on a
choisi les frontières comme repère mois
voilà maintenant plusieurs mois que
vacciner pas vaccinés au départ et
maintenant vaccinée
j'arrive en belgique avec mon q r comme
je suis allé au luxembourg avec mon cul
vers code ya rien de très compliqué là
dedans
si ce qui est compliqué c'est quand on
fera le compte d'une coupe globale de
tous les tests parce que à titre
personnel utilisant une sécurité sociale
communautaire et non française je paye
mon test cash
il est à plus de 50 euros à chaque fois
donc je pense pas que la sécurité
sociale puisse le tout les pays
d'ailleurs puissent très longtemps à
aborder ce coutelas d'ailleurs ça a été
une des discussions dans le cadre du
texte que nous voterons au mois de juin
ce que je crois si vous voulez c'est que
la réduction ad simplement des
dogmatismes du centre au tourisme nous
avait pas beaucoup de retard un exemple
simple du mega man sera sans doute
d'accord avec moi le variant angles est
connu depuis le 1er octobre nous aurons
débarrassions très difficilement en
europe continentale d'élus juin entre
nous soit dit là les vols avec l'un
d'eux sont complètement ouvert vous
pouvez aller venir comme vous voulez
france inde en france tous les vols sont
ouverts et il n'y a pas de quarantaine à
la sortie et ils ce sont les quarantaine
volontaire
je crois que les richesses qui
contrarierait les gens qui sont celles
de faire des quarantaines sur des pays
acp comment avec des variantes très
compliqué ou du moins que comptage et
donc avec toutes les conséquences qu'on
connaît mais aussi obliger tout un
chacun positif à ce
s'isoler réellement et il faut le dire
fermement
pendant les dix jours nécessaires
couperet encore plus au delà de la
vaccination la des précautions
je dois dire que les français ont
vraiment été très très raisonnable
jusqu'à l'ouverture de déconfinement ces
jours ci il ya quand même eu des
réactions nationales qui a été de très
très belles qualités
et pourtant nous avons encore douze à
quinze mille cas par jour
je rappelle que l'an dernier nous avons
des confiner le 11 mai l'épidémie a
redémarré le 16 juin alors que moi
j'étais dans la région marseillaise il y
avait ce fameux varié en marseillais qui
était un petit peu particulier mais le
16 juin tout à redémarrer
donc il faut que nous soyons très
prudent et qu'on arrête avoir du
dogmatisme politique quand il s'agit de
redonner une vie normale à tous les
français tous les européens et même à
toute la planète on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça évidemment on peut
pas monsieur megaman et est en
réanimation il sait le coût de la vie et
les modalités de soi qu'on doit donner
et puis tous ceux qui ne peuvent pas
bénéficier des services de rien normaux
8 mans effectivement là vous vous
faisiez allusion se passe en terre qu'on
utilisera spécifiquement france parce
qu'il faut distinguer le parce qu'on
utilisera à partir du 1er juillet dans
toute l'europe les le pas salutaire pour
les événements de plus de mille
personnes en partir du 9 juin qui a été
approuvé par le sénat français ce qui ne
plaît pas à tous les députés qui sont
opposés comme la député du bas-rhin
martin venait avant de vous faire réagir
je voudrais vous faire écouter
sept députés le sénat s'est de
gouvernement la mise en place du pass
sanitaire covit 19 sur notre territoire
restreindre les libertés des français
est une décision politique et non
sanitaires aucune preuve n'est apportée
quant à la nécessité du pass aucune
preuve quant à la nécessité du pass
bruno m'égare ban qu'en pense le médecin
que vous faites mais écoutez le pass a
été réservée aux rassemblements de plus
de 1000 personnes notamment dans des
festivals temps des réunions culturelles
ou sportives ou effectivement par
définition et un brassage de personnes
venant d'horizons différents qui ne se
connaissent pas qui vont être côte à
côte qui vont se parler crier chanter et
donc effectivement malheureusement même
site s'étend en lieux
ouvert il existe un risque de
contamination
aujourd'hui le virus n'a pas disparu
circulent encore un niveau relativement
important trois fois plus que le niveau
qui serait nécessaire pour pouvoir
permettre des dépistages et des traçages
efficace et donc il faut être
extrêmement prudent
donc je crois que c'est en fait
paradoxalement pas du tout un moyen
d'empêcher la liberté mais au contraire
de permettre la reprise en sécurité de
certaines activités notamment avec ses
fameux rassemblement
par ailleurs je suis convaincu
effectivement que ce pass pourra aussi
jouer un rôle important pour inciter
notamment les jeunes à se faire vacciner
donc tous les moyens sont bons on le
voit qu'un à nouveau ce que la
vaccination le niveau de vaccination va
déterminer aujourd'hui c'est ce qui va
se passer en septembre octobre
si la population adulte notamment les
jeunes ne sont pas suffisamment de
vacciné malheureusement en septembre
octobre on risquerait de voir à nouveau
le virus repartir et à ce moment là
toutes les personnes non vaccinées
courir un risque de faire des formes
graves
mais comme à ce moment là évidemment la
vie aura repris normalement comme bien
sûr il sera totalement impossible
d'imposer des restrictions car les
vacciner ne le comprendraient pas eh
bien ces personnes prendraient d'un
risque direct pour eux mêmes de faire
une forme grave et de décéder
joëlle mélin ce sont quand même des
arguments de bon sens qu'est ce que vous
répondez vous qui êtes ont fait opposés
à ça se passe sanitaires
à titre personnel je parlerai plus à
titre personnel mais même un petit peu
plus largement dans le mouvement dans
lequel je suis nous nous sommes contre
ce pass numérique
je ne vois aucune difficulté comme je le
fais moi encore une fois depuis des mois
comme tous mes collègues toutes les
personnes avec qui je voyage dans le
train dans l'avion d'avoir un document
papier qr codes d'avoir le bon vieux
certificat de vaccination le carnet de
vaccination l'international
jaune et noir ce n'est absolument pas ça
et je partage l'avis de mon confrère
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé hier
soir à lille on peut se dire que compte
tenu du nombre de personnes
statistiquement évidemment dans les
jours dans les dix jours qui vont venir
on va avoir qu'apparaître parce de ci de
là de nouveaux cas pour le rassemblement
cela me semble normal alors qu'il faut
pas confondre ceux qui vivent ce les
cuvées proposées au plan médical et qui
est tout à fait recevable de pouvoir
aller dans des grandes réunions avec la
certitude que vous êtes testées
négatives avec les la marge de manoeuvre
d'erreurs que l'on connait on est
maintenant aussi que c'est pas tout à
fait à 100 % mais sa limite sérieusement
quand même la contamination et le fait
d'avoir un pass sanitaire qui serait un
pass prétendument passeport éternelle ce
qui est faux on va se trouver avec un
vaccin qui va ressembler à ceux de la
grippe dont il n'est valable que six à
huit mois je m'appelle quand même si les
informations sont molles qui a quand
même plus de 500 personnes à marseille
qui était largement vacciner et qui ont
contracté un virus un mutant évidemment
c'est un peu comme si nous avions
plusieurs épidémies à la fois poussines
mais un petit peu différente à chaque
fois
donc évidemment il faut se protéger et
effectivement ça poussera tout le monde
à se vacciner rapidement
encore faut-il pour cela qu'on est la
production et là il y a eu toute une
sorte de mensonges de promesses
mensongères faites alors là au plan
politique par les allemands pendant leur
présidence de dire qu'on allait avoir le
bac 5 pour noël
non un vaccin témoin comme un petit peu
et on n'a pas toujours attendu les fans
phase iii comme le spoutnik l'avait fait
en russie pour pouvoir commencer à
vacciner largement ce qui nous a fait
gagner du temps les phases 2 et 3 qui
font un peu superposés mais on n'avait
pas les chaînes de production des
chaînes de production se met efficace
son temps pour avoir suffisamment de
vaccins pour tout le monde
elle se met en place la queue depuis
avril mais évidemment il aurait mieux
fallu dire aux gens on vaccine
c'est ce qu'on a fait d'ailleurs et les
autres attendent et fait attention on
vous promet pas on va faire des
vaccinodromes avant l'heure et autres ça
c'est les politiques qui l'ont fait au
niveau local s'était pas tout à fait
raisonnable et honnête à l'égard des
gens il convient vraiment con soir
médicaux protecteur hélas oui monsieur
mais garbage partis se partagent votre
avis sur le fait qu'il faut dans les
rassemblements avoir à cuire
les qr codes ou même un test négatif
papier ça ira très bien aussi
merci beaucoup à tous les deux en tout
cas d'avoir exprimé ses arguments à l'un
et l'autre joëlle mélin bruno merial
bannière fait d'avoir été en direct sur
rt france